اقليم كهرباء بؤره الصراع المتجدده بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان بمساحه تقدر بنحو
4400 كيلو متر وعدد سكان يقارب 150 الفا
يقع اقليم كراباخ في قلب الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه ويعترف به القانون الدولي
جزءا منها الى القرن التاسع عشر تعود جذور
الصراع حول الاقليم بعد الثوره البلشفيه
دخلت جمهوريتان المتنازعتان ضمن الاتحاد
السوفيتي وفي عام 1921 تحديدا تقرر بقاء
الاقليم داخل حدود اذربيجان في ظل اعتراف
ارميني لاحقا منح الاقليم حكما ذاتيا لكن
بعد سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي اعلن سكانه
الانفصال عن اذربيجان وصولا الى حرب عام
1993 التي دفعت فيها ارمينيا بقواتها الى
الاقليم وضمته مع اراض اذربيجانيه اخرى
خلفت تلك الحرب الثلاثين الف قتيل وحركه ل
جاوزت مليون شخص مع رجح الكفه
الديموغرافيه في الاقليم لصالح الارمن
تجددت الحرب عام 2020 واستعادت اذربيجان
بدعم عسكري تركي قسما كبيرا من اراضي
الاقليم التوتر الجديد عاد الى الواجهه
بعد تحذيرات مراقبين من عدم استكمال اتفاق
2020 الذي انهى الحرب برعايه روسيه وقوات
حفظ السلام ونص على تبادل فتح ممرات بريه
احدها بين اذربيجان واقليم نخت شيفان
التابع لها عبر ارمينيا والاخر يربط
ارمينيا بعاصمه كاراباخ ويمر عبر اذربيجان
صراع الممرات دخلت في سياقه قبل ايام
تركيا حينما اعلنت في الثالثه عشر من
سبتمبر الجاري بدا العمل على ممر يربطها
باذربيجان ويمر بارمينيا تزامنا مع ذلك
ارسل الحرس الثوري الايراني معدات عسكريه
الى الحدود الشماليه الغربيه المحاذيه
لاذربيجان وارمينيا
تعقيدات الجغرافيا وموروثات التاريخ
ومخاوف اندلاع حرب جديده عوامل تتداخل على
وقع تجدد التوتر في كاراباخ بعد عمليه
اذربيجانيه تقول باكو انها لم تجد عنها
بديلا